a qué se debe que por primera vez la
extrema derecha de suecia pueda hacer
parte del gobierno
bueno los partidos de extrema derecha
han existido prácticamente desde la
década los noventas en toda europa han
sido las diferentes situaciones
que habéis vivido cada país europeo que
ha hecho que los partidos de extrema
derecha pues se haya logrado escaños
importantes a nivel del parlamento
incluso nos algunos han llegado
a ocupar digamos puestos de poder pero
el caso de suecia es muy interesante
porque a pesar de querer desde donde
los partidos moderados han gobernado en
suecia pues prácticamente hay una
preocupación a nivel social muy
importante porque los partidos de
extrema derecha en toda europa y en el
caso de suecia no es la excepción se han
alimentado con un discurso
antiinmigrante que ha tendido a crecer
en el caso de suecia hay una lucha de
pandillas hay un problema social
bastante profundo hay toda una situación
de crisis económica que suecia viene
enfrentando y que se agrava con la
situación de la guerra en ucrania que le
permitió la extrema derecha en este caso
poder utilizar ese discurso para poder
ganar pues votos muy importantes dentro
de toda la dinámica política que suecia
ha venido viviendo y que incluso también
de alguna manera se vio
afectada con las decisiones que
recientemente tomó el gobierno de
magdalena anderson pues para para
acceder digamos a su decía en el caso de
ser miembro de la otan así que han
habido una serie de factores que se han
conjugado perfectamente para que la
extrema derecha en este caso haya
logrado estos votos que en este momento
está obteniendo y como usted bien lo
menciona suecia no es el único caso
hasta qué punto entonces se están
expandiendo los partidos nacionalistas y
anti inmigrantes en europa
bueno recordemos que el el primer
discurso y jean-marie le pen en francia
en la década los 90 es cuando empezó a
pelar por un discurso antiinmigrante al
igual que el caso de gor haider en
austria pues ese fue el reinicio del
relanzamiento por decirlo en estos
términos de los partidos de extrema
derecha que desde ese momento hasta la
fecha no han parado de ganar
gradualmente pues posicionamientos muy
importantes dentro del electorado de los
de los de los países en europa y en
consecuencia pues todos los escaños que
han venido ganando en distintos procesos
electorales tanto a nivel de elecciones
regionales que en algunos para algunos
países europeos este es un tema bastante
complicado a nivel electoral y también
han ganado escaños a lo interno de los
parlamentos en cada uno de los gobiernos
en europa y también incluso en el
parlamento europeo así que este el
discurso que le ha permitido pues eso ha
hecho que los partidos de extrema
derecha en algún momento también hayan
tenido sus altibajos pero eso no ha
minado la posibilidad que para el caso
de suecia o el caso de españa-
recientemente o el caso de hita de
italia también pues haya permitido los
partidos de extrema derecha de la mano
de viktor orbán en hungría que están muy
bien consolidados en el poder un poco
este ir gradualmente pues consolidando
el poder en muchos de los países de
europa